plus de 25 heures c'est le temps qu'il
aura fallu au sénat pour adopter le plan
de relance de l'économie américaine
un projet de loi approuvé sans surprise
à une voix près le texte peut désormais
passer par un dernier vote à la chambre
des représentants ce mardi avant sa
promulgation par joe biden d'ici au 14
mars
le président américain qui a d'ailleurs
vanté les vertus de ce plan ce plan nous
met sur la voie pour battre le virus se
plante donne aux familles qui luttent le
plus contre le virus l'aide et la marge
de manoeuvre dont elles ont besoin pour
traverser ce moment ce plan d' les
petites entreprises de ce pays une
chance de survivre
et encore une chose ce plan est
historique
pris dans son ensemble ce plan doit
permettre de réduire de moitié la
pauvreté infantile et les 6 128 pages du
texte contienne en effet de nombreuses
mesures de soutien en portefeuille
américain avec notamment une aide
ponctuelle allant jusqu'à 1400 dollars
envoyés à une majorité de foyers
la prolongation des allocations chômage
fédéral jusqu'en septembre
350 milliards de dollars aux états et
collectivités locales ou encore 130
milliards aux écoles la lutte contre la
pandémie bénéficiera quant à elle de 49
milliards de dollars pour les campagnes
de tests et de 14 milliards pour la
distribution de vaccins
au total le troisième plan de relance
qu'ovide coûtera la bagatelle de 1900
milliards de dollars au trésor américain
une dépense dénoncée par le parti
républicain
la liste de voeux à 1,9 milliard de
dollars des démocrates est un projet de
loi gonflé coûteux et très partisan et
ceci est réellement mal venue au moment
où un président qui est entré en
fonction en suggérant vouloir travailler
avec les républicains
créer des solutions de manière
bipartisane et essayer de rassembler et
d'unifier le pays met en oeuvre une
première action qui est un texte de loi
fait simplement avec une logique
partisane sans consultation avec les
républicains au considération de nos
idées
résultat le grand old party a rejeté le
texte en bloc les républicains avait
pourtant approuvé les deux plans de
relance précédents y compris les
historiques de 1200 milliards de dollars
adopté en urgence au début de la
pandémie
soûlard trump de son côté la frange des
démocrates modérés a pesé de tout son
poids dans les négociations
preuve que si le sénat a bel et bien
changé de couleur il n'est pas
entièrement acquis à joe biden et que
les divisions partisanes sont toujours
vivaces
on est loin du discours inaugural du
nouveau président qui le 20 janvier
dernier déclarait y aurait des lyonnais